hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for it is round
four of the super United rapid and Blitz
tournament currently being played in
Zagreb Croatia Magnus Carlsen vs alireza
firozan at the match uh everyone was
hoping to see uh next year in the World
Series championship match but as alireza
did not win the candidates Magnus
decided he will definitely not play
although it's questionable if he would
actually play that had alireza won the
candidates tournament but regardless uh
let's see how aledeza handles himself
against Magnus with the black pieces and
what um uh it's very interesting that uh
as the the game features the Catalan uh
what Vladimir kramnik has taught alirez
about the Catalan as kramnik was known
as as one of the greatest Catalan
players ever so without further Ado
let's check it out oh and sorry uh
before uh I show you the game uh here we
even have a nice photo of this matchup
let me just load it up there you have it
let me just make that a little bit
smaller okay there we we go so you can
see as this is not a feeder event the
players don't have to wear suits it's a
bit more casual and I I thought it was
very interesting that alireza has
already defeated Magnus as you can see
Magnus only has a couple of um company
logos on his uh on his clothes whereas
alireza has a whole lot of them so just
something that I thought was very
interesting but if you guys bought
anything else that's interesting also uh
do share in the comments as I very much
enjoy reading what you guys find in in
the photos so let's check it out Magnus
opens with the D4 and we have Knight to
F6 C for E6 and now Magnus goes for the
Catalan uh we have Pawn to G3 d500 is a
bishop to G2 and the bishop to E7 so
going for the close capital and the
absolute Main Line Knight to F3 we have
Castles by both players and now the
captures and C4 we have Queen to C2 and
pawn to A6 and now uh there's been a lot
of Queen captures on C4 lately where uh
black just chases away the queen plays
Bishop to B7 and it's a very nice game
for both of them but here Magnus goes
again for the absolute Main Line Ponte
A4 Bishop to D7 and queen captures and
C4 we have Bishop to C6 now countering
white strong Bishop here and Bishop to
G5 and here uh there are a couple of
moves that are possible you could play
A5 you could play Knight beta D7 H6 is
also very popular but Bishop to D5
alireza still continues in the in the
main line uh we have Queen to C2 and now
Bishop to E4 attacking the queen and now
if you go back with the queen to the
seemingly active C4 Square black and
just continue development and now you
have your queen who where the queen was
and alireza moved two pieces not one so
that would be wasting a Tempo so here
Queen back to C1 and now Knight the C6
um also H6 is is very much played here
but Knight the C6 is basically the first
time in the game on move 12 where we
sort of deviate from the current Uh
current Main Line uh so here Rook to D1
again Knight beta D2 and D3 are the
absolute top moves here Magnus plays
Rook to D1 and now we have Bishop
captures on F3 interestingly Rook the D1
was played only a handful of times one
of the players that tried it is David
Howell he won a won a very nice game
with it but in that game H6 was played
but here we have Bishop captures on F3
alireza plays the absolute top move
recommended by the engine so you can see
that alireza knows even how to reply to
this very very quickly and it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game so Bishop captures an F3 and Knight
captures on D4 a move that shouldn't be
possible because what if we just play E3
uh and uh well it isn't always just
blundering a knight here as the queen is
still on the eight well uh Magnus uh
first says that we have to play King to
G2 if you play E3 right away then this
comes with check and you've just
wandered a piece so here Magnus plays G2
and now all it is it just plays C5 he
still asks Magnus uh uh to play E3 and
if you don't play it there is really no
better move now you you could go for
something like Bishop captures uh here
Bishop captures and F6 and queen
captures and C5 to grab this Pawn uh but
that's kind of what alireza once then he
gets Rook to c18 and now you're playing
uh playing valeres this game so Magnus
goes for E3 he challenges the Knight now
what can the Knight do well there is
only one move Knights the B3 attacking
the rook and the Queen and here you have
to trade Queen so Rook capture 78 Knight
captures and see C1 Rook counter 78 Rook
captures and now Bishop captures on B7
grabbing that pawn back we have Rook the
A7 chasing with the bishop and Bishop to
F3 H6 attacking the bishop and now uh
first uh oh you could capture on F6 but
Magnus goes for Knight to D2 he just
attacks the Knight on C1 so Knight D3
and now only now Bishop captures on F6
we have Bishop captures and now the B2
Pawn is attacked twice so you can't
really defend it and you can't move it
um you will lose the Rook so here you
have to give it up with Bishop to E2
Knight captures on B2 and now Rook to A2
attacking the the Knight here we have
Pawn to C4 uh giving up giving up that
pawn uh you could try something else but
um alireza obviously obviously has this
very much prepared because he played
much much faster than than Magnus did he
had some maybe 10 10 16 or 17 minutes on
the clock whereas Magnus said 10 minutes
on the clock if I forgot to mention in
the previous videos this is rapid chess
uh players have uh 25 minutes uh each a
plus 10 seconds increment so here we
have Pawn to C4 giving up that pawn
Knight captures on C4 Knight captures
and the bishop captures on C4 uh we have
Pawn to A5 now with equal material and
with Bishops of opposite color so it's
very very unlikely that this will end in
anything but a draw uh Rook to D2 by
Magnus now comes Rook the C7 attacking
the bishop Rook to C2 and now Pawn to G6
with Bishop to D3 offering The Rook
trade and uh there really isn't anything
better characters captures and now of
course both of them know this is a draw
but they will each make a few more moves
to make it um uh I don't know if there's
like a limit because they drew and move
33 so obviously the players can draw at
any point but maybe they can't uh below
move 30 I'm not sure about that one so
here H4 G5 H characters H captors and G4
and it was in this position and move at
33 that LEDs and Magnus agreed to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
and as these were the standings
yesterday alireza was leading the
tournament with five points and Magnus
was a second with with uh four uh this
means that uh of course alvareza Remains
the leader after round four of this very
nice tournament uh so uh or rather no
they did not uh they did not agree to a
draw here they played a few more moves a
dance of the Bishops uh occurred here
Bishop D3 Bishop here Bishop C2 and here
in after Bishop to D3 unmove 36 they
agreed to a draw yeah so sorry about
that I forgot about the the bishop dance
right there uh so yeah uh very very
impressive stuff from alireza a
completely neutralizing one of magnus's
strongest weapons the Catalan defense G3
uh with this line where he just had a
complete control over the entire game it
didn't seem like Magnus could do
anything uh he found the improvement
with Bishop captures on on F3 and he
even allowed the Magnus for playing this
C5 move to go for this line that we've
mentioned but then aldireza gains the
initiative and well it would be uh it
wouldn't be very safe for magnets to try
and pull this off if he doesn't have it
prepared and it does seem like all it is
I had it prepared so very very
impressive stuff completely neutral
neutralizing uh the the Catalan from
Magnus uh
very nicely done it would seem uh
Vladimir kramnik prepared all it is a
well maybe not well enough for the
candidates but it definitely well enough
to to face Magnus uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and that
you've you know learned to appreciate
the Catalan a little bit more I would
like to thank John Austin Michael
Higgins Dominique Albers Gordon Merrick
and sankot solo for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on this wonderful
tournament and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and a few more seconds of
this nice photo uh before we end the
video
see you soon